dificultad un sombrero típico de su
provincia natal de y un lápiz
gigante esos son los símbolos con los
que pedro castillo hizo campaña para la
presidencia de perú este profesor de
izquierda ahora es el candidato que
lidera las votaciones en el país andino
algo impensable en marzo cuando castillo
apenas comenzó a aparecer en las
encuestas siempre por debajo del 4 por
ciento de la intención de voto y sin
siquiera estar en los grandes debates
pero en abril tuvo un repunte meteórico
y hoy es el candidato más opcionado
nadie me hace con el deje de ser
político dirigente oscuridad pero
el camino se hace al andar
agradezco enormemente a mi pueblo
la primera vez que pedro castillo fue
visible en todo el país fue cuando
lideró la huelga de maestros en 2017 y
allí también surgieron los señalamientos
con los que ha cargado desde entonces
quién era el ministro del interior
aseguró que pedro castillo fue el líder
de las protestas porque dos movimientos
señalados de ser el brazo político del
grupo sendero luminoso lo respaldaron
las acusaciones han revivido en la
elección aunque castillo lo ha negado y
enfatiza que el apoyo se lo debe en gran
medida a los profesores
[Música]
de acuerdo a este dato quiero agradecer
enormemente
[Música]
así yo quiero cambiar la constitución
para darle más poder al estado destinar
el 10% del pib a salud y educación y
crear un nuevo tribunal constitucional
elegido por el pueblo pero en otros
aspectos el docente es más conservador
pues dice que no legalizará el aborto ni
el matrimonio igualitario se opone a la
eutanasia y está en contra del enfoque
de género en las escuelas lo que ha
pasado con su candidatura es un reflejo
de lo imprevisible que puede ser la
política en perú y cuya presidencia se
definirá en la segunda vuelta en junio